- Having your movies out in a pandemic,
has anyone had the chance to like,
ask you for your autograph?
I mean, it's kind of weird
'cause you're not really out.
So have people really
noticed you anywhere yet?
- You know what, I,
that hasn't really happened yet.
Like, I haven't had a,
sign my first autograph
or anything but just online,
I've kind of seen through the critics
and through social media,
certain fans that have,
people have really been
responding to the work,
which is, it's a nice feeling, yeah.
- Wait, are you saying
that you haven't actually
signed an autograph yet?
- I, when I was a basketball player,
I signed a couple for like
kids and stuff, but no,
I've never signed one for acting.
Not yet, no.
- Oh my gosh, can I be your first?
Will you sign it?
I loved you in the movie.
Will you sign an autograph for me?
I'm going to put it up in my studio.
- Wait, are you serious?
- Yes.
- Okay, I mean.
- I want you to sign something for me,
I'm gonna put it up in my studio.
- Kelly, is there any
way, 'cause my sister,
I gotta say.
Wait, Kelly, Kelly, all right,
I was trying to play cool
throughout the interview,
but I got to get down for a second.
My sisters and my parents and I,
we watched every single
episode of the first season
of American Idol.
So this is like, so what I'm saying is.
- Are you Team Justin or Team Kelly?
I'm just kidding.
- How 'bout this, how 'bout this?
I mean, I've seen the movie,
I've saw from Justin to Kelly, so both.
- Oh my God, that was
contractually obligated.
While you have...
- My sisters and I loved it,
my sisters and I loved it.
We have to take that somewhere.
- But I love that y'all
watched the first season.
That's that's so cool.
Okay, I promise you this,
I'll sign something for your family
if you send something for me.
- I was gonna say, my sisters and my mom
will kill me if I don't return.
So can we do like a little trade off?
Is that, is that cool?
- Yes, tradesies.
And I'm not kidding, the next
time you come to my studio,
I'm gonna have it like, hanging
up in the room you're in.